say mommy say mommy
that was anna nicole smith's daughter
danny lynn burkhead
when she was just a baby in 2006.
fast forward to 2021 and
danny lynn is now 14 years old and looks
all grown up i mean overnight she just
is sprouting up danny lynn attended the
kentucky derby at churchill downs in
louisville kentucky on saturday
and her dad larry burkhead was right by
her side
sharing these snapshots from their
outing on instagram
which included coordinating
father-daughter ensembles
he captioned the post in part quote it's
that time of year again
adding that his teenage daughter who
rocked a giovanni pantsuit
and white flower fascinator to the event
wanted to wear something
entirely different than she had in the
past
quote i guess that means no more little
girl dresses
she cleaned out the chocolate brownies
ice cream and nachos while at the same
time
critiquing my outfit i'm so proud when i
look at her
and i think that you know how how far
she's come
the kentucky derby is a special event
for the family
they've been attending the celebration
together since 2010.
it's just as much fun as it was from day
one if not more
last year the sporting event was
canceled due to the pandemic
at the time larry honored the annual
tradition by posting
this sweet throwback with danny lynn and
joked in the caption
sharing this memory of simpler times and
a kid that didn't talk back as much
danny lynn's mom anna nicole died in
2007 from an accidental overdose
and in 2017 over a decade after her
death
larry sat down with e.t and opened up
about how his daughter has been coping
without her mother
as she enters her teenage years she is
clingy to
teach her the female teachers she's
clingy to her
girlfriend's moms
and she'll say things like would you
want to adopt me as you know would you
be my
you know you know honorary mother will
you be my
you know so she she tends to do that and
despite the struggles of being a single
dad
larry said he couldn't be more proud of
the young woman danny lynn
is becoming she had a friend whose
fish died and she said um
[Music]
she said don't worry about your fish
it's up there with my mom
and um
she said my mom's taking care of your
fish
and if it's gonna be okay and so
it you know it wasn't scripted it wasn't
something i said to her it was something
that she came up with
it wasn't somebody saying your mom's
auntie nicole
you're this she it was something that
was true from the heart and that's how
she deals with it and she says
and it's um and for that i'm proud that
she's
um who she is
you